Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P Continued confusion,
folks. Am I a socialist or not? I am not
a socialist. But the confusion continues.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. This is. I'm from
Atlanta, Georgia. Well, I want to ask you
what used to be you used to call yourself a social
Democrat couple of years ago. Yeah. And I want to
ask what label best describes your politics
now in 2022? Thanks. I want to say goodbye.
Speaker 1: Okay. It's actually 2023. With all
due respect, I know we're all making that same
mistake. I'm still doing that anyway. I this might
come as a shock. I am still a social Democrat,
social democracy being a well-regulated form of
capitalism. I am still there. And. Yeah, I don't.
The confusion about my politics has certainly
increased lately, but I am still not a socialist
and I know there are people waiting anxiously
for that to happen. But for the time being, I
am still a social Democrat. We have a great bonus
show for you today. Texas has a bill which would
ban nearly all gender affirming care, including
for transgender adults, adults who are supposedly
able to make the decisions that they believe are
best for them. Lawyers for Donald Trump propaganda
Steve Bannon are now suing Bannon over legal
bills. Apple doesn't fall far from the tree, does
it? And a Florida lawyer argues that a pregnant
inmate's fetus is being illegally detained. This
actually could be a really big deal case. All
of those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: No comment on that. But I
do invite you to join us on the bonus
show. Sign up at join Pacman dot com.